SEAN MCQUILLAN: With the
launch of Jetpack and the KTX
libraries, we've made
Android development
even sweeter in Kotlin.
But our apps rely on more than
just the Android libraries.
As app writers and
library maintainers,
there's a lot you can do
to be Kotlin friendly.
First, you should update
your existing code
to follow the interop guide.
Then you can start building
Kotlin specific APIs.
This video will cover
the interop guide,
which covers best
practices for writing code
in the Java programming
language to support Kotlin.
It has four main
interop suggestions.
First, Kotlin is all
about null safety.
To support this in the
Java programming language,
add the annotations
Nullable and NonNull
everywhere in your public API.
Kotlin will use these to
make your API null safe.
Now, what happens if you don't?
Well, Kotlin makes what's
called a platform type.
It's a heisen type that
can be null or non-null,
and it leads to heisen bugs
and NullPointerExceptions.
When you do use
annotations, Kotlin
will make your API
null safe, fixing
the NullPointerExceptions.
Getters and setters are
important for interop.
Kotlin requires they
follow the bean style--
getName, setName,
isActive, setActive.
When you do this, Kotlin will
elevate them to properties,
so they can be used naturally.
Next, Kotlin adds
support for lambdas,
and you can interop with them by
using single abstract methods.
Examples of single
abstract methods
are runnable and callable.
When defining your
API, make sure to put
your single abstract
method parameters last.
Then Kotlin developers can
make full use of lambdas.
And finally, Kotlin has
some different keywords,
and it's important to
avoid name conflicts.
If you do provide a function
called is, developers can still
call it by saying back tick is
back tick, but let's be honest,
that is not a good look.
For a full list of keywords,
check out the interop guide.
To help support
interop, we've added
tooling to Android
Studio 3.2, introducing
lint checks that will warn
you for all interop issues.
To use them, enable the
interoperability group
in Gradle.
Another tool for
Kotlin is Dokka.
If you're generating
documentation
with the Java doc tool, you
can migrate to using Dokka.
Dokka will generate
your documentation
and it supports both languages.
There is a lot you can do to
make sure your existing code is
Kotlin friendly.
In this video, I covered how
to follow the interop guide,
and we'll cover
how to make Kotlin
specific APIs in a later video.
Thanks for watching.
See you again next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]